the truth about women is they are always
going to be a weakness for a man and in
every possible regard like
let's take very simple examples if I
were to get arrested I have no concerns
no problem I know how to handle it if a
woman close to me gets arrested the
first thing in my mind is [ __ ] what's
she gonna say does she know to shut up
like even if her heart is pure even if
she wants to protect me she might just
say the wrong [ __ ] women women are easy
to attack the government will attack
your woman your enemies will attack your
woman like advertising to the world your
weakest point is foolishness so yeah you
can't do that and a lot of people who do
it are gonna either they're certainly
gonna end up regretting it I ask you
Richard you can tell me have you ever
seen a dude like completely obsessed
over a chick and simping over and
telling the world how great she is who
doesn't end up regretting it like Kim
left Kanye Tom Brady's [ __ ] laugh like
all these girls that are believing
anyway it's like and now you have now
the reporters go okay we want to see if
Tom Brady likes some butt stuff let's
just call his ex up like it's crazy yeah
you're just advertising to the world
attack vectors and I don't think many
men think far ahead enough to understand
this yeah it's a dumb argument it's
always like well you know show us proof
let's look guys these are the same guys
that know that women like Rich
successful funny competent strong
virtuous like men right it's like
who do you think's getting the girls
dummy that's right yeah if they're not
if they're not [ __ ] some somebody
more successful than you so don't then
who they [ __ ] don't worry about it
bro and yeah it's it's hate never comes
from above right but all these trolls
and clowns and all this garbage they're
always going to do it but they're
looking for attack vectors and you
simply can't give it to them because the
world's unhinge as well bro like we were
talking about the fame thing earlier but
one of the one things that started
happening since the fame thing is that
uh people are trying very hard to work
out where I am and they might come with
good intentions but if I'm in a hotel
and I don't advertise it and someone
manages to work it out and turns off at
my hotel asking for me that scares I
don't like it at all and it happens
quite often and even my house in Romania
the country that nobody goes to I now
have armed guards at my house I have
four men with [ __ ] AR-15s outside the
gate and still there'll be some dude
from turkey or some random kid from
Amsterdam that flies himself to Romania
finds my house and turns up trying to
talk to me so it's weird so on top of
that I'm going to say about my woman my
woman who she is where she works what
she does no that's crazy it's done all
right I mean I've been doing this for a
while but I never post anything on
social media until I've left that area
right I mean if I'm at a hotel or if I'm
at a certain Resort or a certain area
like I never share anything unless I've
left that area and I think that's good
advice for any guy out there that's the
way to do it the only other thing that
you have to be careful of is metadata so
metadata yeah metadata on on pictures so
let's say you're chilling in an area and
you take a picture and you send it to
someone and they managed to look at the
metadata on that photo which is quite
easy to do it has the exact location
so then then they can leak your location
right so that happened to me once or
twice this is about a year ago so now if
I want to send a photo I take a photo
and I take a screenshot of that photo
and send a screenshot because if you
send the photo itself it has the
metadata the locations building
is this a conversation that you've had
to have with women because I mean like
women typically are like well why don't
you share pictures on social media with
us like you don't love me or like what
is it sort of thing it's like no you
don't understand right like that like
there's a reason why
yeah when bro women don't get your ass
killed who's that rapper who just got
killed PB rock or some [ __ ] he got
killed in L.A yeah yeah that's right he
was with a girl in a restaurant dinner
yeah yeah and they blasted him outside
yeah well she's probably [ __ ] someone
else by now and you're dead so women
will get you women will get you killed
fast and you're right and women don't
like the idea of being protected and
censored in that way they're like oh why
don't you show us Etc because they want
to pretend they don't know the realities
of the world sometimes it's difficult to
sit down with a woman and just explain
to her I have enemies and people don't
like me oh yeah but you're strong what
do you mean I'm strong listen there are
people that are all grouped or gangs
armed who don't like me like you can't
just be sitting there [ __ ] saying
where we are put your phone away
it's just a harsh reality of it and uh I
know a lot of high-level guys who just
take their take the phone off the women
like sometimes especially if you go to
parties in Dubai the second women walk
in the door all the phones are in
lockers and women are allowed phones
because they're just irresponsible with
them they don't think ahead yeah um so
yeah it's annoying but it's just a harsh
reality of Life have you have you
changed your delivery much since since
you got canceled you know before versus
after like have you thought about that
much like maybe I need to revisit the
way that I use these sound bites
yes I am more careful now than I was
perhaps yes that's true my delivery has
changed I don't think I say anything
less I don't think I've sold out but my
delivery has certainly changed
um and also
I'm trying not to give the Matrix easy
ammo against me but also I was fighting
a PR War for a while and I know I was
fighting a PR War so when I first got
canceled I went to my team and I said
look because there's there's software I
don't know exactly what it's called I
think it's called social mention but
there's software that analyzes uh
YouTube videos and and Instagram posts
Etc and analyzes the comments how many
are positive how many are negative how
many are for you how many are against
you so we started running reports and at
the height of the cancellation when all
of the Matrix was attacking me it was
around 50 50. 50 of people liked me 50
of people believed I was truly bad for
the world and we decided we had to
change that because by winning the pr
War it takes away a lot of the Matrix
weapons
and we've won the pr War so now when you
analyze it it's 97 positive only three
percent negative so I had to be a little
bit more careful with what I said for a
while I had to change the delivery a
little bit because a lot of people
aren't ready for the harsh harsh truth
but um yeah I kept it in mind I kept in
mind that things can be chopped up and
used against me but I still think I'm
going to say that I still think I'm
saying the same things my message hasn't
changed and I never lied to anybody
anyway I never said anything that wasn't
true like the things I've been attacked
for at length like saying women can't
drive they can I'll say it again they
can't drive I'm sorry and you can't
drive and I'm not going to sit here and
lie to you or anyone else and pretend
you [ __ ] can because you cannot yeah
and it's just the reality of it right
and and I it's kind of funny you know
like Manny koshbin me and him were
talking a little bit Yeah and then he
put up a video with with Supercar
Blondie and she they were in the in the
trailer they did some click bait where
she almost it looked like she almost
crashed she probably didn't almost crash
she probably made a small mistake yeah
but they put up a trailer with some
click bait of her almost crashing or
something and I wrote underneath it bro
women can't drive what you doing yeah
and uh he unfollowed me and stopped
talking to me got all upset about it
well I brought what the [ __ ] it's
[ __ ] why is everyone denying this
harsh reality of Life women can't drive
cars I can and they're gonna try and
they've tried to scare me into shutting
off but I refuse I stick by the truth
and I got a reward before no I'm with
you on that 100 like and I can prove
that through ways one how many women do
you ever see on Supercar rallies very
few they're almost always in the
passenger seat I think I've been on one
rally where a chick was driving
um take a look at any woman's car that
you've ever dated they've always got
scrapes the bumpers kind of hanging off
like there's always dings and dents all
over the car and three yeah
the father off yeah like
and then Formula One drivers how many
Formula One drivers are are female and
that's not to say that women can't drive
like get from point A to point B it's
just they somehow managed to
it's not a huge priority or an interest
for them to sort of you know compete in
that realm otherwise you would see them
in Formula One sort of thing they just
want a car to get from place to place
and you know their cars will get dinged
up it's just a fact it's just a reality
of life right yeah and this is the thing
that's so crazy we live in a world now
where you can't say men are better
drivers and women but women are better
at raising or more tolerant with kids
than men something [ __ ] obvious okay
even if you support women in something
else you can't say men are better at one
thing it's [ __ ] clown world and
they're doing that because they
understand that it's not about elevating
women that's not what it's about it's
about it's about reducing it's about
reducing men dragging men down
demasculinizing men that's what they're
interested in they don't give a [ __ ]
about raising the spirits of women they
just want men to feel like [ __ ] so
that's why they do these things and they
sit there and say that little girl over
there she can drive a Lambo just as good
as you and I absolutely reject that
because it's a [ __ ] fallacy lie hey
guys I really hope that you enjoyed that
short clip if you did consider
supporting the creation of content by
check checking out my supplement line
pinned in the top comment below of this
video in the comments there's a link to
the unpluggedalpha.com forward slash
shop when you click through you'll be
able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational Essentials
for health immune Health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code Alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the Subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching I
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out